you're in the middle of our tournament
where my friend John said he found a
body in the bushes over there I ran over
there because I'm a healing monk to try
and help but obviously my magic wasn't
strong enough because the dude's body
was missing a head felt my friend
decided to try and use a necromancer
spell which didn't work which I knew it
wouldn't and apparently we contaminated
the crime scene because that spell uses
a lot of glitter
Dave Rubin this is the Reuben report it
is April 4th 2023 and we had to start
you with a little satire cold open there
because I saw that video yesterday it
was making its way around the internet
and we have entered a strange I would
say uncanny valley portion of humanity
right now which is where it is
impossible to tell if something is real
or satire at this point it turns out
that that clip which looked like it was
from a local news recap on someone being
beheaded in the forest it turns out that
the guy's a comedian and it was satire
but we just can't tell anymore because
the news is getting more Ridiculous by
the second and today is a day that will
go down in the history of ridiculousness
uh because Donald Trump obviously uh
with this arraignment and the indictment
and the whole thing we're going to be
covering that and a bunch more today but
it's just it's a bad day it's a bad day
guys period uh whether you support Trump
whether you like the santis more
whatever regarding 2024 for the state of
America if you believe in Law and Order
if you believe that we have to believe
in the system for it to work that we
shouldn't be hounding and chasing former
presidents because once you do it once
you open up a door you open up a
Pandora's Box and what will happen after
that where we will just have one
president who eventually ends up in jail
and another president who ends up in
jail and that's how you end up in an
autocracy that's how you end up
in a dictatorship where a leader never
wants to leave remember when we invaded
Libya that was under Barack Obama we
didn't call it a war so he didn't get uh
Congressional Authority we called it a
kinetic military action I had never
heard of that before it sounded
something like Xbox Connect or something
uh Gaddafi ended up because he couldn't
leave right there was no way he could
leave he knew if he left power he was
going to end up dead he ended up hiding
for a while and uh one of they chased
him down and somebody literally jammed a
knife up his butt and that's how it
ended for Gaddafi there there's video of
it we didn't want to play it for you
because it's before noon uh but the
point is that if you if you start going
down the path that we seem to be going
down right now we will end up in a
terrible place because you know
generally speaking not not entirely but
generally speaking good people no longer
want to get into politics because it is
dirty it is evil there's all sorts of
things you have to do the money the
fundraising like it's just a freaking
mess this swamp the Machinery all of it
the media right so you already have it's
already selected for a certain type of
person to get in well now if you start
also saying to people and by the way if
uh your president one day and even if
you're fairly successful as president
we're going to try to figure out how to
get you either way you're going to end
up in jail One Way Or Another We're
going to do everything we can to destroy
you and your family post presidency
after we did it for four years while you
were president this is dangerous stuff
we will end up with no good people in
politics maybe that's where we're headed
regardless uh but that's going to sort
of be the outline for the show today
sort of comparing how the media is
covering this what some of the other uh
candidates on the Republican side are
doing right now but I thought an
interesting way to start uh would be
this video from one of the debates in
2020 I believe this is the first debate
the first Trump Biden debate in 2020.
and here's Trump outlining all of the
witch hunts that he's gone through all
of the things that they tried to do to
destroy him before he was president and
while he was president and while he was
trying to become president for a second
term which obviously didn't happen but I
think this is an interesting way to
frame Today's Show I listened to Joe
talking about a transition there's been
no transition from what I want I won
that election and if you look at Crooked
Hillary Clinton if you look at all of
the different people there was no
transition because they came after me
trying to do a coup they came after me
spying on my campaign they started from
the day I won and even before I won from
the day I came down the escalator with
our first lady they were a disaster they
were disgraced to our country and we've
caught them we've caught them all we've
got it all on tape we've caught them all
and by the way you gave the idea for the
Logan act against General Flynn you
better take a look at that because we
caught you in a sense and President
Obama was sitting in the office he knew
about it too so don't tell me about a
free transition
okay so I don't want to get into every
little thing he said there but the the
facts of the matter are that Hillary
Clinton paid for the steel dossier that
then the entire Russia collusion hoax
was based on that seems to me to be some
level of a criminal act when he's
talking about the Logan act related to
General Flynn that you can't be
negotiating basically talking to foreign
governments without the authority of our
government it's like what was Hunter
Biden doing in Ukraine which he
obviously got the job through his dad
like there's the point is there is so
much criminality related to politics and
high-level politicians especially at the
international level you don't think that
Ukraine right now is a giant money
laundering operation How does Barack
Obama who was a community organizer and
a senator for a term or so before he
became president how does he now have
how much is his house in uh Martha's
Vineyard it's a 30-acre house on the
water it's got to be worth at least 15
million bucks how did that happen how
did Elizabeth Warren who makes a 258
thousand dollar a year salary become
worth 67 million dollars how did Bernie
Sanders socialist far left doesn't know
the difference between equity and
equality Bernie Sanders how did he
become a millionaire who owns three
houses Barack Obama's house I was close
I I put it up at 15. it's only worth 12
million 30 Acres it's a steal strange
he's living on the water with all that
climate change stuff but the point is
there there are so many criminal
activities that these people either do
intentionally or unintentionally Nancy
Pelosi worth like a hundred million
bucks Gavin Newsom worth all of this
money like they all become part of the
thing and they're trying to get Trump
now because he paid off a porn star for
prostitution which sounds kind of
unclear now they've they've no pun
intended trumped up a whole bunch of the
other charges that should be
misdemeanors that now sound like they're
going to be felonies this guy's is
Banana Republic level stuff and let me
just say one more time you know over the
last couple weeks I have been very
critical of trump
I like Trump I voted for trump it cost
me a lot to support trump it cost me
friends it cost me sponsorships
obviously all sorts of stuff it wasn't
like the most fun thing to be the guy
wandering around in La as like one of
the the loudest and proudest Trump
supporters I enjoyed it when I was going
to the rallies but you know when your
neighbors uh see you they're they're
generally not thrilled with you but I'm
very proud I feel like I did the right
thing and and by all measures uh this
country would be in a much better place
if Donald Trump was President I have
been critical of them over the last
couple weeks because his fire to me was
aimed the wrong way this indictment was
potentially coming there's you could be
attacking all day long the ridiculous
ineptitude of this Biden Administration
and he was going after DeSantis the guy
that he backed two times who who he
lives in his State and all of the crazy
name calling and all that stuff so I was
critical of him on that but I just want
to be clear there is no daylight here on
on the absolute farce that that this
indictment is and speaking of farces
here's Joe Biden comment or lack thereof
on the Trump indictment
no comment not even anything about ice
cream just absolutely nothing so what
does it mean if you have no comment
about this do you not care about our
democracy do you not care about the
justice system do you not care about
equality under the law or how about
basic virtue or morality or or the
rights of the individual Joe Biden knows
that the swamp in the machine is doing
his dirty work we have an 80 some odd
year old man who has dementia or
something close to it who sometimes
shakes hands with air who often walks
downstairs and asks people for ice cream
when he's supposed to be giving you know
a talk or a speech he is confused he
doesn't know what's going on he really
doesn't yes they can make him Lucid for
two hours a day somehow with whatever
drugs they're putting him on and they'll
do it again for the next mates because
somehow they're going to put this guy up
again it's it's
absolutely ridiculous but he can't
comment on this he has no comment why
wouldn't his comment be well I I stand
with uh the NY uh D.A I stand with Alvin
Bragg New York why didn't even say that
he doesn't have the balls to say that
but Trump has been predicting something
that I think uh is clearly coming true
you know one of the lines that Trump
always said was they're not coming after
me I'm just standing in the way meaning
they're coming after you
and I think we're sort of seeing that
we're seeing that if you if you are on
the margins of what Society will allow
whether that means you're good or bad is
completely irrelevant uh they will come
for you and they are looking to destroy
you and they're looking to disassemble
every facet of your life through Trump
so you don't have to love Trump
and again I've been very critical of him
like I'm I'm tired of a lot of the name
calling I'm tired of it all being about
him all the time I think we have to get
past some of this stuff but if you want
to take a principled position a
principled position is this is this is
an absolute farce and this is clearly
only because he is running in 2024 if he
had just gone out to pasture right just
gone back home to Mar-A-Lago and just
said you know what I'm just gonna hang
out amongst the gold and the women with
all the plastic surgery and we're going
to have our little parties and I'll wear
tuxedos and people will come and say how
great I am and I'll eat all the fancy
foods and blah blah blah and just lived
out his life this would not be happening
this is clearly happening because of
2024 and
that's not how the justice system is
supposed to work so we got a lot to
unpack on today's program related to all
of that before we do let me talk to you
guys about balance of nature you know
nothing is more fundamental than the
fact that fruits and vegetables are good
for you but eating all the fruits and
vegetables you need can be time
consuming and expensive which is why I
take balance of nature I took them this
morning it gives me a foundation of
nutrition and the positive effects of a
wide variety of fruits and vegetables in
just a couple seconds see why hundreds
of thousands of people take balance of
nature every day get 35 off your
preferred order your first preferred
order when you use discount code Dave
that's right 35 off your first order
just by using discount code Dave and now
back to me okay so there's always two
things that are happening here we have
sort of
what's actually happening so Trump is
being indicted like this thing is
actually happening and then we have the
way the media filters the truth right
the media could respond honestly to the
truth they could even the people that
are Trump deranged could be going uh you
know imagine wouldn't this be refreshing
if someone on CNN or someone on MSNBC or
or a columnist in Washington Post or New
York Times wouldn't it be refreshing if
they were like you know what over these
last couple years I I've been very
critical of trump some would say I've
had Trump derangement syndrome I was
thrilled when he got out of office you
know blah blah blah I called him Hitler
and his supporters racists and
deplorables but I don't like the way
this thing's going right now there's a
dangerous slippery slope here and this
could come for all of us where is that
type of principled person I think you
could very easily connect that to the to
the failure of the people who I'm
usually most critical of these days
which are the the last remaining
liberals this is this is the fault of
sort of these people like if there's
ever a moment to be principled now is it
but I can't find any of them being
principled so you have the truth that is
happening what's really going on on the
ground and then you have the way the
media responds to it
so I apologize guys well we are showing
you some view Clips but we're going with
Stephen Colbert first so here you go
have a dire warning for average citizens
it's not even about Donald Trump it's
about every American because if they can
do it to Trump they can do it to you
with this indictment I think it's an
indictment on everybody in America I
mean if it can happen to him it can
happen to you and I but if they can do
this to Donald Trump they can do it to
you if this is what can happen to him it
can happen to anyone if they can do that
they can go after you and me it's true
if this indictment stands then no one
who has their fix or pay six figures and
hush money to their porn star lover then
reimburses that fixer out of business
accounts then falsifies it as legal fees
and conspires with the publisher of the
National Enquirer to catch and kill
stories about his other extramarital
Affairs as part of another illegal
violation of campaign Finance laws will
be safe
folks
you know the old saying first they came
for the former president and I said
nothing because he is so guilty
comedy it ain't what it used to be look
I don't even think we have to comment on
the specifics of the charges it's again
it's largely irrelevant there's a
certain set of people that want him in
to be in jail that want him to be in
jail no matter what a certain amount of
people that want him to walk no matter
what what I'm talking about here is sort
of the the Blue Sky version of this is
what direction this will send the
country in if this guy ends up in jail
where will it send the country it will
send the country to hell it really will
and Stephen Colbert man you know I
always say the thing about Stephen
Colbert it's that line I used with Bill
Maher that that he was into that Stephen
Colbert just gives the machine what he
what it wants and what Stephen Colbert
is forgetting is that people like him
people like Brian stelter these types of
people who just give the machine What It
Wants they do whatever the sort of
spirit of the day is eventually the
machine doesn't need you anymore and
when the machine doesn't need you
anymore it gets rid of you and the
Machine you could be applauding there
are taking Trump to jail they're going
to get Donald Trump now Colbert they
could come for you for one reason or
another one day that's also why so many
of the walksters are former comedians
who used to be politically incorrect
then they feel this guilt so they have
to run cover for their former guilt
anyway now we got to show you some of
the ladies of the view they are thrilled
what an incredible day it was yesterday
as all this was unfolding for the insane
did we put the warning we put the word
put the warning again let's really drive
it home for the people
yeah it's the view here we go
and to quote the great Sunny Hosten the
Detroit same twice in peace I can't even
speak twice a peach the twice impeached
one term once indicted but who's
counting former president is reportedly
facing more than 30 count them criminal
charges so
how do we feel about this unprecedented
moment in American history I called it
did you
when I feel good foreign
[Applause]
ly responsible because no one is above
the law he would be at the very least
charged he not only has the New York
case he has a Georgia case he has the
Department of Justice cases though there
are two or three of them there I mean
you can't commit so many crimes and
think that you are above the law even if
you are the president
the audience you know that if the
audience of the view is not sure when to
applaud that you might be missing
something I think the audience is
actually smarter than them they are
thrilled that the guy that they hate is
potentially going down they don't care
why he's going down or what evidence
there is or isn't or as I'm talking
about here what this does to the fabric
of the country the amount of people who
feel that Trump was unjustly attacked
you know it's funny Joy Behar is talking
about two impeachments two impeachments
that nothing came of them the January
6th hearing that nothing came of it the
Mar-A-Lago raid that nothing came of
that like how many times again as Trump
said at the beginning in that first clip
they were going after him before he was
president with the Steele dossier and
everything else so all of these things
have systematically failed and they've
but because they went all in he's Hitler
we got to keep going and keep going and
keep going so now they're the audience
is is being queued to applaud because
they don't even know what they're
applauding I think the audience might be
going but maybe this is just a bit much
uh here's Anna Navarro and a Navarro she
put on a little extra makeup yesterday
you'll see in just a moment she was all
zazzed out and she's very excited that
the grand jury is gonna go for him
listen the first
personal grand jury because they have
been meeting for weeks and weeks they've
done this incredibly seriously this is
not an easy case this is this is a case
that has risks and so I thank them
because these are regular New Yorkers
these are not people with a political
agenda these are regular New Yorkers
Donald Trump finally won a popular vote
yesterday
the grand jury voted to invite him you
know I was thinking last night boy
because I was reading this article where
Ivanka and Jared apparently want to
start their new life in Miami and I was
thinking you know they now can give
their children the distinction of having
matching mug shots for their both of
their grandfathers yeah you can pick
whether you want Charlie Kushner or
Donald Trump mug shot if you are Jared
and ivanka's child
she she really is terrible you know let
me let me say something on a personal
note you know we've become pretty
friendly with Ivanka and Jared over the
last couple months since we got here
when we got down to Miami I got a note
from Jared hey heard you moved down here
uh would you guys like to come over for
dinner they are good people they are
good decent people
um and
they absolutely have my support and that
that she finds this fun Anna Navarro
finds this fun that that Jared and
ivanka's children will have matching mug
shots it's just so gross you know it's
so interesting too because what she's
doing she's thanking the grand jury
she's thanking the grand jury but it's
hilarious because if the grand jury had
gone the other way she would be telling
you that the grand jury was corrupt she
doesn't know what information the grand
jury has or doesn't have but she's
thanking them because she's getting the
result that she wants had the grand jury
looked at the evidence and we don't know
what pressure they were under I love how
she's saying well these are just regular
New Yorkers they're not political people
you know we're all humans in society
politics affects all of us Trump when
you guys have trumped him up to be
orange Hitler that concept is sort of in
an awful lot of people's brains people
that end up on grand juries so she has
no idea whether the grand jury was
politicized or not she simply has no
idea but this idea oh the grand jury is
good when it does what I wanted to do
but you know damn well if the grand jury
had tossed away the charges she would be
sitting there today today telling you
how corrupt the grand jury was the
system is screwed up they should have
another trial they should find him on
something else burn it all down yada
yada
I don't like those ladies of the view
guys
I want people to know it uh let me talk
to you guys oh we we sorry we have one
more here uh if you want to know a
little bit more about the uh the grand
jury these people and you go well these
are not these are just regular citizens
they're not political people do you
remember when uh Georgia well Georgia
now has another case going against Trump
but then they did have a case about a
month and a half ago that got thrown out
this is a video did we show this on the
show or did I I don't think we showed
this on the show uh this isn't this
really is incredible now just to
contrast what Anna Navarro just said
right there these are just regular
people that are on these grand juries
right as if they they exist in vacuums
they are not affected by anything they
have no political leanings or biases or
anything else we all do okay it's part
of Being Human if you're going to be a
functioning person in society so this is
a woman who was the four person on the
Georgia grand jury uh that in the case
that got thrown away okay now there's
another case coming but this is about
two months ago and tell me if the four
person you're the four person on the
jury you're kind of in charge you're
like wrangling the cats and trying to
get everybody who to agree on stuff now
they threw the case away but you tell me
does this woman seem unbiased and sane
and the type of person you wouldn't want
in charge of who goes and doesn't go to
jail
personally want to hear from the phone I
wanted to hear from the former president
but honestly I kind of wanted to
subpoena the former president because I
got to swear everybody in and so I
thought it'd be really cool to get 60
seconds with President Trump of me
looking at him and being like do you
solemnly swear I'm beginning to swear
him in I just I kind of just thought
that would be an awesome moment
what do you want me to do what do you
want me to do with these people like if
you grow up like that girl she probably
I don't know what if she looked maybe
and she's in her late 20s something like
that like a generation of people who
talk like this and they just don't
really care about the law about what I
really wanted was to like sit him down
and like be able to say something in
front of him like that's what I want to
do
it's a miracle he didn't get caught hung
up on that one you know I've heard from
a couple people that I trust that the
the Georgia case against Trump which is
a separate thing altogether this this on
upcoming Georgia case is much stronger
than the New York case that's just a
little sidebar but we're getting some
breaking news right now so I'm just
reading this as it's coming in uh it was
just leaked to Yahoo that Donald Trump
is being indicted with 34 case e
felonies for falsification of business
records today but he will not be
handcuffed placed in a jail cell or
subjected to a mug shot per Source from
the DA's office well that's interesting
look I didn't think that they were going
to put him in jail uh it is interesting
that they are not going to do the mug
shot the mug shot which of course would
have ended up being as iconic uh as the
MLK mug shot so that's probably a wise
move they were about to make him even
bigger than he is at the moment a little
more info on a classy felony leaking a
grand jury disclosure which sounds like
this is what just happened to Yahoo also
how happens to be a Class E felony in
New York punishable by up to a year in
jail so whoever leaked this thing but we
never find out who leaks things when it
helps Democrats right remember the
Supreme Court leak Roe v Wade was going
to be flipped we decided not to find out
who did that right when things work for
the Democrats would always tell you
there's only one type of privilege in
America it's Democrat privilege so this
is interesting because it sounds like a
bunch of the things really were
misdemeanors that uh that Bragg has
upped to felony charges so he may be
overshooting here let's cross our
fingers and go all right the guy's
overshooting they're not going to be
able to convict him on the the way the
charges are constructed so
we shall see but but it is not good we
got we got plenty more on this uh let me
talk to you guys about Birch gold real
quick uh you know inflation has
consequences and as the FED raises
interest rates to combat out of control
government spending long-term bonds have
diminished in value crippling banks
depositors are holding their breath and
investors are bailing on Bank stocks
diversification has never been more
important the recent surge in gold
prices is directly tied to the extreme
Market volatility right now this is why
gold has historically been a fantastic
hedge against the stock market and
against inflation now would be a great
time to diversify into gold with Birch
gold group Birch gold makes it easy to
convert an IRA or 401K into an IRA and
precious metals here's what you need to
do visit birchgold.com Dave to get a
free info kit on gold they'll help you
convert your existing Ira or 401K that's
tied to a volatile Market into an IRA in
physical precious metals gold and silver
and the best part it's tax shelter visit
birchgold.com Dave to claim your free
info kit on gold today they've got an A
plus rating with the Better Business
Bureau thousands of happy customers and
countless five star reviews Birch gold
is who you can trust to protect your
future birchgold.com Dave today okay so
let's get into a little more perhaps
there I say honest assessment of what is
going on here so I can show you clips
from CNN and I can show you clips from
The View and you get it they're getting
what they want and not only are they
getting what they want because they want
to destroy Trump but they're also going
to get views and clicks right who's
thrilled about this right now every time
something goes on with Trump the ratings
go up for these guys that it is a simple
truth it is just truth so they have to
be enjoying that at some level your
ratings go up you get more ad dollars
more people are paid more money in the
pocket okay fine that's how the game
works but not everybody is a complete
dishonest Arbiter that is in mainstream
media there are a couple people that I
think are at least ballparking it to the
best of their ability right that's what
I'm trying to do ballparking at to the
best of my ability that's what they
could put on my Tombstone Dave Rubin he
ballparked it to the best of his ability
uh here is uh do you want to do the
statement from Trump first we'll do that
first
yeah okay so first before we get into
some of the media things let me let me
read the statement that Donald Trump
posted on Truth social and then we'll
get into some of the media guys this is
political persecution and election
interference at the highest level in
history from the time I came down the
golden escalator at Trump Tower and even
before I was sworn in as your president
of the United States the radical left
Democrats the enemy of the hard-working
men and women of this country have been
engaged in a Witch Hunt to destroy the
make America great again movement never
before in our nation's history has this
been done the Democrats Have Cheated
countless times over the decades
including spying on my campaign but
weaponizing our justice system to punish
a political opponent who just so happens
to be a president of the United States
and by far the leading Republican
candidate for president has never
happened before ever I believe this
Witch Hunt will backfire massively on
Joe Biden the American people realize
that realize exactly what the radical
left Democrats are doing here everyone
can see it so our movement and our party
United and strong will first defeat
Alvin Bragg and then we will defeat Joe
Biden and we are going to throw every
last one of these crooked Democrats out
of office so we can make America great
again you know I have to say you know
I've been critical of trump because of
some of the language he's been using
mostly related to DeSantis right you
back a guy twice you love the guy he's
the best governor in America you live in
a state all that stuff now you're
calling him a rhino and a globalist and
claiming he's a pedophile like all of
that insane over the top stuff that was
a pretty clear
that's the clear and cogent Trump that I
think would be the better Trump at this
point and he is right there there's
nothing factually wrong in what he said
there they funded the steel dossier as
we talked about already they have been
trying to take this guy out from day one
and he's right he's right about this
idea you go after him with this you
weaponize the justice system after him
and congratulations Democrats you will
not always be in charge and it will come
after you as well and now to some of the
people who are ballparking it roughly
right I would include my good friend
Glenn Beck on that he was talking to
Tucker Carlson last night about what it
is the Democrats have just ignited in
this country
are the Republicans where are the decent
Democrats that can see this is this is
insanity Donald Trump the reason why
this is going to help Donald Trump and
that's why I don't think they're doing
it so he can't run they're doing it
because they want people to strike out
please turn to God repent pray for our
country Pray for Peace put on the full
armor of God but here's what's really
what they miss
Donald Trump is not even a person
anymore he is a symbol he is a symbol of
the average everyday guy that keeps
getting screwed every single time
watches other people so screw up big
Banks screw up their companies and get
away with it he's they see people all
the time doing stuff that they know if
they did they'd be in prison for 20
years but because they're not part of
the elite they get away with it Donald
Trump has taken Arrow after arrow and
that's why
this is the way the average American
feels tonight and there's going to be a
hundred million people that will walk on
broken glass and Through Fire to vote
for someone other than this corrupt
Banana Republic Administration
I think exactly right Glenn Beck wow you
know let me tell you something about
Gladden you know obviously you guys know
Glennon I've interviewed him many times
and I and I know Glenn personally Glenn
is the most soft Pleasant like
light-hearted fun smiley guy so when you
see Glenn with that with his sort of
brow down like that and with the with
the tone that he's talking about it's
like he really really means it and I
think he's right I'm not going to put a
hat on because I just got a haircut
yesterday and I'm feeling quite good
about it so there will be no hat being
put on for me today
um but I think Glenn's main point there
is right Trump it's he's not a person
anymore there is a human Donald Trump
that human who wears the suit and the
red tie hangs out at Mar-A-Lago and you
know sends out his true social messages
but that's not what this is about
anymore he is right this is a symbol
this is a symbol go back to the the
Christopher Nolan Batman movies about
the importance of a symbol right and
Donald Trump is now a symbol and if they
can destroy him if they can figure out a
way to do this
who else will they come for how else
will they come for people will they ever
let go of control will we end up with
basically sort of these broken States
we'll have all these different broken
State I mean maybe we have this already
to some degree because the blue states
are so broken but really corrupt Justice
systems in certain States less corrupt
Justice systems in other states there'll
be a constant war in a federal
government that nothing will ever get
better I mean maybe we're in all of that
stuff right now and Trump's the last guy
to do something about it
I don't even know the Trump's the guy
that can fix this thing I mean that
that's sort of been my calculation if
you're talking about the bigger problem
about actually draining the swamp
getting things to be a little more
normal and everything else I don't know
that he can fix it if he was sworn in as
president in a couple of years it's like
maybe all hell breaks loose again and
they they unleash the riots in the
streets and they burn everything down
and maybe he can't get good people to
work for him because too many people
will be afraid or he's turned against
too many people or whatever my
calculation has been all along that that
DeSantis is the better choice on that
but it that is utterly irrelevant it is
utterly irrelevant we cannot end up in a
situation where we do this because we
will we will end up with only worse and
worse people forever
I discussed just that with Vivek
ramaswamy his new podcast launched
yesterday we taped this about two weeks
ago I was the first guest on his podcast
so we taped this two weeks ago just as
the uh indictment was announced so this
is right after the indictment was
announced but I believe it was before
Tuesday right
uh it was either before the Tuesday that
it was about to happen or it might have
even been that day but you can see we we
disagreed on a bunch of stuff if you
watched the whole thing it's about a
two-hour conversation but one thing we
fully agreed on was the the
circumstances surrounding Trump's
indictment
it's wrong we should not live in a
country
where the political party in power uses
the police state
to arrest its political opponents that's
the stuff of banana Republics
we're skating on thin ice as a country
right now and I don't care if you're
democrat or republican whether you're
Joe Biden running against Donald Trump
whether you're me running against Donald
Trump or whether you're Ron DeSantis
running against Donald Trump
it's a moment that calls for principle
rather than political calculation that's
why I spoke up about this I I I I guess
I assume that you feel the same way but
I guess I can't be I'm not sure about it
so I'd love to hear your opinion on the
Trump situation but that's what's on my
mind today but I think it
makes me think more deeply about these
questions of leadership in our country
too right now
sure so let's start with the easy stuff
the the agreement stuff and for sure the
only thing we discussed before we
started recording this is that we're
going to get into everything sort of
with no rules and there are points of
disagreement that we'll gladly get into
but I can very easily just to jump off
on the Trump stuff completely agree with
everything you said right there we are
potentially entering and maybe we've
entered it already Banana Republic level
stuff
we're back we're back oh sorry
I was looking at myself and then I'm
back okay that's me I think I might be
wearing the same thing
look this is where we're at it doesn't
matter if Vivek and I don't agree on
everything and if you watch the podcast
and I recommend that you do we you can
see we get into a bunch of things that
we disagree on tactics and and tone with
a few things
um but this is good to see Ron DeSantis
come out and lay out that statement we
will not extradite this guy it's a
George Soros back D.A this is complete
corruption for a D.A that is letting
people off of Major Crimes and this is
selective enforcement laws so we're not
going to be involved in this that's
great vivec
who could draw blood from Trump right
now so you can see when people have a
moment to to stand up like if Trump was
arrested this helps vivec right like
vivec is going after the populist crew
so if Trump is out Vivek would rise very
quickly but Vivek is taking the right
position there I think Nikki Haley has
also taken a similar position so these
people and this is what I've been saying
all along about the sort of wide swath
of Republicans and we'll see who else
gets into it I'm going to show you a new
guy who just announced in just a second
um but right now this this swath of
Republicans that's getting involved
these are pretty decent people even if
you disagree with them on certain things
and I mean that about Trump I mean that
about DeSantis I mean about vivec I mean
it about Nikki Haley uh one that I'm not
so sure what I think about is uh ASA
Hutchinson who is the former
governor of Arkansas you know why don't
we flip the order of these videos can we
do the second one first he's just
announced that he is running for
president in 2024. I have made a
decision and my decision is I'm going to
run for president of the United States
while the formal announcement will be
later in April in Bentonville I wanted
to make clear that to you Jonathan I am
going to be running and the reason as
I've traveled the country for six months
I hear people talk about the leadership
of our country and I'm convinced that
people want leaders that appeal to the
best of America and not simply appeal to
our worst instincts and that inspires me
when I see everyday Americans just
saying give us good leadership give us
Common Sense consistent conservatism and
optimism about our great country and
that inspires me and I believe I can be
that kind of leader for the people of
America okay so that's ASA Hutchins
Informer governor of Arkansas as I said
he is going to be the type of Republican
that is going to get a lot of mainstream
press right because he won't really have
any support but the mainstream media
will tell you this is the type of of
Republican we should have this is the
type of sort of mitt romneyish nice guy
looks nice enough we can Pat him on the
head sort of thing I I have no doubt
he's a decent guy I will gladly
interview him I'll treat him the way I
treat all of my guests of course but you
can see a little bit of the game that
gets played here so we're just pulling
back a little bit of how the media
operates and how these candidates
operate he knows he's not going to be
president he knows there's there's no
need for his candidacy because if you
want competency and decency in those
things let's say you let's say you just
hated Trump right so you just hate Trump
for all the reasons that you might hate
Trump if you want competency and decency
like you've got DeSantis and Nikki
already so he's just doing his thing but
I promise you he is going to be he is
going to be loved by mainstream media
because he is the type of sort of it's
just sort of like having like an asexual
guy at a singles bar you know what I
mean like nobody's threatened over this
guy but then he went on uh another show
and here he is going after DeSantis
because DeSantis is standing up for
Trump I mean my God here we go
over the weekend Governor DeSantis who
very well may be one of your competitors
for the nomination called Alvin Bragg
the Manhattan district attorney a menace
to society you yourself you are a former
prosecutor what did you think of that
well I think it's appealing to the worst
instincts of America versus trying to
sort through a difficult time in our
country and so I look at what Alvin
Bragg the district attorney has done and
I have said that if the facts are as I
understand it as a former prosecutor I
wouldn't bring that case but we also
need to wait to see what the facts are
there's a lot of unknowns that are here
in addition you've got two additional
investigations that are ongoing
do you see why why he'll be a media
darling like you can see it right like
you're a former prosecutor what do you
think about this prosecution well I sort
of think nothing's of it but I need to
like he's just gonna always give them
what they want so that he can keep being
on TV and people can be like DeSantis
and Trump who are the real threats
obviously whichever way you want to go
on that they're scary can we put up this
guy that's what it's going to be this is
also a guy who has not done a
particularly great job I don't think
we're gonna have to focus on him too
much over the coming months but he has
not done a particular great job a
particularly great job I should say uh
in defending conservative values uh when
he was governor of Arkansas last year he
vetoed a bill that would have outlawed
gender assignment surgery for minors uh
something by the way that Rhonda Santa
signed into law in Florida today that
happened today like an hour ago we
didn't get in our rundown because it
happened so recently we'll try to get
more on that tomorrow uh but here's
Tucker a year ago asking Lisa Hutchinson
why he would Bill why would why would he
veto such a bill
Sign Pro why are we regulating the
behavior of children at all if we're
allowing children to decide and by the
way I read a study today that showed the
overwhelming majority of kids who do not
take life-altering hormones in the end
decide not to quote transition to a new
sex so there's a lot going on here but
I'm asking as a conservative you just
incited invoked Ronald Reagan as if he
were for chemical castration of children
what other Behavior should we not use
the power of the state to regulate among
kids seriously
well yeah every time look Tucker you
want to keep talking you want me to
answer a question
well thank you and so whenever you
whether it's it's beer for minors these
are all issues that you have to address
the legislature you make judgment calls
on it but we also try to restrain
ourselves as conservatives and say we
don't have to be involved in every issue
and if you want to broaden the party if
you want to get back to the principles
then let's at least think through in a
reasoned way as to whether this is the
right Bill to interfere with parents and
doctors decisions on a health care
matter as you pointed out has does not
have thorough research in every area and
so I yield to that but whenever you look
at this bill if I yield to the lack of
research
it's so interesting to me that a
conservative can take that position
there is a difference between
conservatism and libertarianism
libertarianism the idea that only really
individual rights matter and the state
should have virtually nothing else to do
with anything right it should protect
property rights and things of that
nature but that's basically it ASA seems
to be taking the libertarian position on
that but the conservative position is
that there are things to conserve like
reality like genders like family things
of that nature and he doesn't seem to be
willing so there's a place to use the
government and he just doesn't seem to
be willing to use the government when
the government should be used I would
say the government should be used when I
when a crackpot doctor is telling a
nine-year-old that if we give you
certain hormones and perform certain
surgeries on you we can make you the
other sex which is not real that is a
place where perhaps the government
should have something to say about it it
because it's medical malpractice at the
very least and we can go into a whole
other uh set of issues on that right you
know my feelings about that but you know
when I was watching that clip it
reminded me of something else remember
that clip we showed you about a month
ago when Mike Pence was on CNBC and he
was criticizing Ron DeSantis for using
government power to take away Disney's
special rights and it's like wait a
minute are you guys conservatives or are
you Libertarians are is Mike Pence a
pure libertarian and never wants the
government to do anything well either
way that wouldn't be the libertarian
position in that case because you would
want equality under the law for
everybody and Disney had special rights
old DeSantis did was take away those
special rights so there are applicable
moments for the government to do
something but these guys suddenly think
that if it's involving if it involves
going after big corporations like Disney
the government should do nothing and if
it involves protecting children the
government should do nothing it's really
bizarre but speaking of bizarre
um you know there are very few I have
not seen any actually I would love to
please send me this especially you guys
in the locals chat if you are finding
any liberals or moderates or non-trump
supporters who are saying the right
thing right now I would love to promote
them I really would because we looked
this morning but the Liberals on this
are are just failing one at a time and
Jon Stewart who at one time was a decent
liberal who has gone off the deep end he
loves he loves trans kids and all this
whole thing uh here he is uh he was on
CNN with Fareed Zakaria uh talking about
the Trump indictment and again
my position has been
we don't know all of the details of
everything but where this is going to
take the country but listen to Jon
Stewart with the slightly different take
the rule of law does not take into
account if that might make you a martyr
to somebody I'd much rather have the
conversation be what is the law
what exactly are we saying that that he
did his lawyer went to jail for this
same situation for a couple of years so
what is the crime is it a crime
the reason for people who say it's
selective prosecution that this would
not everything is selective prosecution
the reason why Donald Trump became
popular in the first place and the
reason why these populist movements is
that the citizenry
have become fed up with the lack of
accountability
for those in power
you know it's funny John got the end
right there that is why what drives
populist movements that the citizens
have had it we see they live one way we
live the other that they lie about
everything blah blah blah but John also
could use a mirror because one of the
other reasons that Trump became
president was because people were sick
of people like him people that mocked
everyone who didn't believe exactly what
the progressive notion of reality was
and who didn't go along with whatever
was happening in the day or who right
now is Jon Stewart's doing on his show
that nobody's watching that he's getting
paid a ton of money for uh you know he's
constantly pushing uh trans operations
on kids and the rest of it so you guys
get that also the way he throws that
line out there everything is selective
prosecution as if that excuses anything
that may be true to some degree right
it's actually the reverse of what Anna
Navarro said Anna Navarro said you know
we can trust these grand juries because
they're apolitical people somehow they
exist in a vacuum and they don't bring
any of their feelings in on it so they
can do their work honestly Jon Stewart's
saying well it's all anyone can have
anything can happen right like it's just
selective it's it's selective people
decide to do things they don't decide to
do things well if that's the case again
you might want to take a more principled
approach let's say you're right about it
John let's say everything's selected
like there are different pressures on
DA's there are different pressures from
the Governor from the constituents
what's going on in that state which way
the political winds are blowing the
media and all those things let's say
you're completely right about that then
why not take the principled position
right now John Stewart why not just sit
there and say you know what Fareed this
is messy this is messy and Michael Cohen
did go to jail and Trump probably
you know did pay off this porn star blah
blah blah but where we will end up if we
go down this route is a very dangerous
place again Hillary Clinton paid for the
fake dossier that led to Russia
collusion what are we going to do about
that lock her up remember when they were
chanting lock her up and everyone was
saying this is the worst thing ever
but speaking of locking people up one of
the things that they don't do in
California is lock people up Jon Stewart
sat down with Gavin Newsom Gavin Newsom
who has demolished the state of
California uh and Jon Stewart slightly
to his credit here went after Newsome a
little bit but then kind of excused most
of it because what's happening right now
in California is first off they're
taking felons they're lowering them to
misdemeanors they're putting less people
in jail they're letting more people out
of jail Petty crimes aren't going to
jail you can trespass they won't arrest
you certain amount of drugs they won't
arrest you you guys get the the amount
of things that this leads to and the
Decay that has happened in Cali which is
why so many people are fleeing but
here's uh Stewart basically massaging uh
Gavin newsom's record over crime and and
allow giving him in essence a past but
it's not it's not horrific but it's
mostly pretty bad
this system isn't built
to cherish each individual and get them
to see their own worth no this is built
to keep them from killing each other
while they're in here correct but as a
society you're right we have to actually
believe in the core tenets of what we
practice in our faith right in that
second damn chances and Redemption Mary
Reese you wanted uh to commute her
sentence you sent her back to a parole
board she's been in prison for a series
of burglaries not nothing but clearly
not a violent offender right she failed
her parole hearing based on having
borrowed I think hair gel from another
prisoner and some other things and on
the flip side of it you have an offender
who was let out and killed a police
officer yeah recently
devastating devastating yeah that
person that killed the police officer
the district attorney
excuse me being responsible that's right
for that I live the realities I don't
know them it's not intellectual that's a
living sure that's I mean and that puts
you on your heels no it didn't put yummy
he'll actually put me on my toes right
you want reform and you want to be I
want Public Safety I want real Public
Safety I want people to feel safe it's
about your own self-interest right it's
so interesting to me it's about your own
self-interest Gavin Newsom doesn't give
a about anyone's self-interest in
California after what he's done for the
last couple years and what he's done on
crime and the way he destroyed San
Francisco and Johnson reporting oh yeah
you're right on that one dude but the
first part the opening part of that clip
is what the most interesting part is and
then I think this goes to what the flaw
and why I think it actually is to some
degree a spiritual issue here not a
political issue Jon Stewart opened that
by saying the system isn't built to
cherish these people and get them to see
their own worth
well that's not what the system is
designed to do our system because we are
all flawed people hoping to build a
system that will just protect our
individual rights things that Gavin
Newsom doesn't care about our system was
built to do three things in essence it
was one thing really but protect what
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness protect life we're going to
make sure we have a police force and an
army so people can't invade and your
murderer is not going to show up at your
house Liberty your ability we're going
to protect Liberty you will decide who
you want to communicate with who you
want to have in your inner circle what
you will want in your local community
that's Liberty how you will live your
life what you want to go pursue and then
of course the pursuit of happiness not
the guarantee of happiness but because
we will make sure that you're not going
to get killed to the best of our ability
and we'll make sure that you can do what
you want to do hopefully or at least try
to go for that then you can pursue
happiness wouldn't that be sweet
wouldn't that be sweet and that was
although it may sound old and it was
written by a bunch of old white people
who are long since gone it was pretty uh
Innovative for its time and it still
stands the test of time but why I say
it's a spiritual thing
is you can sort of see what what lies
behind the mind of a liberal Jon Stewart
gets up there Bill the system is wrong
the system doesn't cherish people the
system doesn't get people to see their
own worth yeah because that's not what
the system's supposed to do what kind of
system are you talking about would be a
system that does not exist people can't
even do it in their own lives in their
own homes fathers can't do it for their
sons half the time right and you guys
wish you could build a system where
everyone would be cherished but then you
put elect dingbats like Gavin Newsom and
well here we go here's a great segue so
what is Gavin Newsom doing right now so
that people can cherish their lives so
that people can see their own worth well
he's letting a whole bunch of people out
of jail uh this is from Fox News uh Bill
malugan uh the LA County Board of
Supervisors has quietly added a proposal
on Tuesday's agenda that seeks to
decarcerate and depopulate La jails by
directing law enforcement and courts to
vastly expand the use of sight and
release and return to covid emergency
bail schedule because you know it was
going so well during covet in La The
Proposal would also ask the sheriff to
cite and release anyone with a bail of
fifty thousand dollars or lower which
could include possession of child porn
domestic violence illegal carrying a
firearm a firearm and violent offenses
like residential burglary robbery and
assault with a firearm The Proposal was
put forward by LA County supervisors
Hilda Solas and Lindsay Horvath as part
of a care first jail less jail last
agenda
the road to hell is paid paved with good
intentions I don't even believe these
people have good intentions anymore I
don't know what intentions they have but
you get it you get it this is look I get
it Gavin Newsom is not in charge of La
specifically but this is the Machinery
of California it punishes good
law-abiding citizens so if this passes
that means in a week from now
or whenever it would go into effect the
guy who's been in jail for three years
for beating the crap out of his wife is
going to show up at home again because
we care more we jail last the woman may
not be so thrilled with that right the
chore the child porn people they'll be
out again because we care more we jail
last that's what these people do they
ruin absolutely everything and every now
and again a symbol shows up
to shine light on their corruption and
as Glenn Beck said Donald Trump is that
symbol and that is why they are going
after Donald Trump so I want to show you
this video it's about two minutes long
this was created by the the Trump team
the Trump War Room team on the Twitter
machine uh and they put this together
just in the last day or so in light of
what is going on with this indictment
Durham probe into the Russia collusion
host president Trump has just been
impeached on both articles the only
President of the United States to be
impeached for a second January 6
committee releasing its final
845-page report former president Donald
Trump has been indicted remember this
nothing worth doing
ever ever ever
came easy
following your convictions
means you must be willing to face
criticism from those who lack the same
courage
to do what is right relish the
opportunity to be an outsider
Embrace that label being an outsider is
fine embrace the labor
because it's The Outsiders who change
the world and who make a real and
Lasting difference
the more that a broken system tells you
that you're wrong
the more certain you should be that you
must keep pushing ahead this is a party
that wants an outsider battle I continue
to believe Mr Trump will not be
president you must keep pushing forward
never ever give up there'll be times in
your life you'll want to quit you'll
want to go home I can't do it I can't do
it just
[Music]
you will build a future where we have
the courage to chase our dreams no
matter what the cynics and the doubters
have to say you will have the confidence
to speak the hopes in your hearts
and to express the love
that stirs your souls and you will have
the faith to replace a broken
establishment with a government that
serves and protects the people
if they're not coming after me they're
coming after you
I'm just
just standing in their way
and I always will stand in their way
thank you
[Music]
I mean that's good that's solid that is
Trump messaging at its best that that's
the Trump that I want to see as the
candidate if he is able to continue
running despite all of this right like
that's the stuff that you watching this
supported that's the stuff that I
supported and I think that's where his
focus should be
um but he's right guys you gotta keep
the Hope right like if they're going
after him we don't know what comes after
that but you cannot stop you know I got
a text yesterday uh and then my my buddy
texted me something and I was like all
right we got to talk this out on the
phone he texted me something basically
saying you know Dave you're probably
pissing off a lot of powerful people do
you ever get worried about it and I
called him up and we were chatting about
it I was like first off maybe maybe I am
maybe I'm not who knows like there's I'm
not saying I'm the only one doing
anything like this right there's plenty
of other people doing this sort of thing
but am I on a list somewhere or somebody
angry with me like avenuesome's probably
not thrilled with me it would be a
problem for me personally if he became
president of the United States like okay
fine
but you can't stop Trump is right like
if you know what is true and you are
fighting something that is bad you just
gotta go you just gotta go towards it
and I think if you go towards it if you
go towards whatever you want you know
that that Beacon
out in the distance you go towards that
shining City you go towards that flame
if you keep going I think something good
will happen one way or another it
doesn't mean it's going to be goodness
all along like you're going to take
slings and arrows and everything else
but that's what we're in the midst of at
this moment we have a completely corrupt
judicial system
certainly coming out of New York in this
case
combined with a completely corrupt
corporate press that is trying for the
800th time to take out the one guy who
was standing up against the entire thing
who became the symbol for the rest of us
that maybe we can beat the thing now I
don't know if we can beat the thing
but we gotta try
right like what else are we gonna do you
want to just be the frog and the slowly
Boiling Pot hint does not well end up
well for the Frog so never give up on
America guys the the Fight Continues and
uh one final clip for you if uh if we
were to give up
what would we be left with Well we'd be
left with people like Hillary Clinton
people like Kamala Harris people like
Nancy Pelosi here's Hillary and Nancy uh
just this is just days ago discussing
election interference in our democracy
by Vladimir Putin which I thought we
weren't allowed to talk about or get you
booted off YouTube but yada yada here we
are
when secretary Clinton was in the Senate
and first lady but especially a
secretary of state in more recent time
she was she has been and at that time
implemented many things showing
America's support for democracy it was
her clarity
and positioned through the present
Putin present occupant leader of of
Russia that made him turn around and
Ensure
in a illegal way
come out against her in her campaign an
interference in our democracy by
Vladimir Putin because Hillary Clinton
was the person he feared most in terms
of his lack of democracy in Russia
that's I think self-evidence and thank
you for what you have done what is wrong
with that woman's brain
if your mom everyone picture your mom
Mom I love you hope you're watching the
show today if your mom you went home and
your mom started talking in that way
right with these broken sentences that
don't really make any sense hands going
out you go we got to take you to the
doctor something ain't right here there
is something wrong with that woman also
just putting aside everything that she
said right there Donald Trump was
President for four years under those
four years Vladimir Putin did Jack
he took Crimea which was part of Ukraine
under Barack Obama he invaded Ukraine
under Joe Biden who was the guy that was
between those two presidencies it was
Donald Trump so it's all just nonsense
also somehow that he went after and
corrupted our elections I actually
thought we weren't allowed to talk about
that and I thought the whole point was
well you got it you guys got it guys uh
we are still putting out a whole bunch
of the interviews couple left uh from
our trip to DC uh yesterday we put up
our interview with Jim Jordan and Byron
Donalds the full things up across
platforms right now we've got a post
game show in about 37 seconds if you
want to add some comments questions
etc
etc we leave you with a cold close
cringe Jean-Pierre in clown outfit enjoy
I'll see everybody else in a couple
seconds
and our hearts go out to uh those the
trans Community as they are under attack
right now
[Music]